So the answer is the first three are all good reasons
to focus on how time scales with input size, rather than absolute
time. So the first reason is if we have an understanding of
how the time depends on input size, well then, we can predict
how long it will take before we actually execute a program. If
we have to run the program to figure out how long it
takes, well that's not going to be very useful because we have actually
finished it. We have got the result we want. If we only
learn how long it takes on that particular input, we
haven't learned anything useful to figure out, what it will
cost to run it on some other input. So we
want to be able to make predictions, by understanding how the running
time depends on the actual size of the input. The
second reason is also true. By understanding how time scales with
input size, we get a better idea of how the
cost will change over time. Computers keep getting cheaper and faster.
>> This was observed by Gordon Moore in 1965.
And turned into the notion that we sometimes call Moore's Law
today. It's not a law in the sense of a physical
law, but it's a law in the sense that the history
of computing has followed this trend, where the amount of computing
power you get for the same cost, approximately doubles every 18
months. So what you can get for $1,000 today is half
what you'll be able to get for $1,000 a year and
a half from now. That's a pretty nice property to have,
but it means that understanding the cost of something today
doesn't tell us very much. What we really want to understand
is the cost in a more fundamental way. The third
reason is also true. That by understanding how time scales with
input size, we get a much better fundamental understanding of
our algorithms, than if we just had some absolute time measurements
for a few different inputs. The fourth answer is not
correct. Abstract answers can be just as wrong as concrete answers.
But having good abstract answers will allow us to understand
things much more deeply, than a few specific concrete answers will.